what advice would you give to young
people
high school college
dreaming of uh
living a life worth living
what advice would you give them about
career or maybe just life in general
kind of a life they can be proud of
yeah i don't know how you're going to
react to this given given sort of your
expertise but i i would say um oh put
down the smartphone yes step away from
the monitor right because real life
is not a screen
i i believe that sort of
the foundational skills which are
which are conducive and important to
success
aren't necessarily those technical
skills
which we're going to learn in trade
schools or or university i think them
they're more foundational than that
they're learning how to interact
um and listen with humans with humans
yeah to really see
and listen
right
um and observe and observe right um and
how to step out of your door and if the
electricity goes out right and you're
five miles away from your house you
don't need a smartphone to get home
because you've set visual markers for
yourself on how to get back to where you
live right i think we're in danger right
now
of
living in a world where if the
satellites stop functioning right um
then a whole lot of people become
completely
dysfunctional right because we're so
reliant upon the screens in our lives so
i think there's a lot of foundational
skills that have nothing to do with
technology that we need to learn that
ever that and everything rests upon
those so i would say learn those
foundations learn how to write well
read a lot
right
it's a different kind of knowledge and
wisdom that comes out of that
so reading is kind of the equivalent of
listening and observing and writing is
kind of
uh integration of all of that that
you've observed and listened to and
tried to express something with that so
i think my training in the theater
has served me so well in the documentary
world right because it's all about
interaction and listening and talking
and dialogue right and that's what i do
in documentaries right is i listen
yeah i yeah i'm we mentioned fear
i'm being an introvert i'm very afraid
of people but i'm drawn to them
i've been fascinated by them because of
that yeah enjoy listening to them
totally and
um
observing them and you mentioned reading
you mentioned books as a catalyst as a
stimulator of your imagination is there
books in your life
a couple one two three
that kind of
left an impact or or a little bit of
spark of inspiration
early on in life
that stand out from your memory i i was
given um the profit by kelio de braun
when i as a graduation present from my
eighth from my high school english
teacher
and i still have that book in a special
place on my bookshelf because i think it
speaks to
the nature of human experience right and
i return to it all the time
because there's wisdom there you know
but but there's uh many many books so
fiction or non-fiction what what
connects with you usually
in the past when different i read mostly
non-fiction most of the time um ten
points is a book i love a lot
what is it what is ten points ten points
is um i think his name is bill
strickland he was the editor of i think
bicycle magazine
and it's sort of his personal memoir of
um his experience growing up with a lot
of abuse and how that transformed him as
a human being
you know one instrumental book for me
that i bumped into in my early twenties
boy these are all non-fiction
except for the princess bride
i have to mention it's an outlier
no no the seven habits of highly
effective people yes um i read that in
my early twenties yeah and i found
so many of um the principles in that
book what are what are the habits from
that one
uh
seek first to understand than to be
understood is one of them you know the
notion of proactivity is one of them
um it's it's really and so i've held on
to some of those principles through my
life as well
you